lothric convergence of the transitory
lands was once ruled by a king in his
queen it wasn't always the shamble of a
kingdom it is today with undead filling
the streets and a Mad King raving loony
seas in the lower Garden it used to be a
place of strength and prosperity before
the king of this land Osiris
became the consumed King he ruled his
domain with power and controlled it with
the pillars of lothric the scholars the
priestesses and the Knights the Knights
were the clear physical powerhouse of
lothric and kept it safe from foreign
enemies their status as a pillar is
solidified by the strength aggregating
Knights ring in lothric the knight has
long been considered one of the three
pillars of the kings rule and were thus
allowed to rear dragons long ago the
Lawford nights were dragon hunters which
explains why so much of their weaponry
is imbued with lightning the trademark
of dragon hunting however the Knights
eventually tamed the drakes and with
them crushed anything they threatened
lothric chores the Knights were the
guardians and protectors of lothric and
her people they were honored as such the
Knights were known as sharing a place as
a symbol of lothric along with the
wyverns and even the armor they wore
solidified their dignity for only those
possessing the Knights resolve were fit
to wear such a garment they now patrol
the high wall and the castle holding
steadfast to their duties to purge any
outsider and keep their home safe all
the Knights had their strength and
Dragons the scholars had the knowledge
of the grand archives dominion over the
grand archives and proof of the pillar
standing is found in the scholars ring
in lothric the scholar has long been
considered one of the three pillars of
the Kings rule and is therefore master
of the grand archives with this great
store information the scholars delved
into a world of sinful sorcery they
defile the sacred chime of the heavenly
daughter Gertrude to fit their needs as
the crystal chime which granted the
scholars a degree of success in this
case the work enabled the chime to be
suitable for casting both miracles and
source
according to the Archdeacon great staff
but the scholars did here by mixing
miracles of the Gods and sorceries of
man was a sin that seems to have matter
not to these corrupted academics who
seemed to think their own desires
paramount to the kingdoms the scholars
were well aware of the power that is
knowledge gave him the law through so
they protected their intellectual
treasure by sealing the doors to the
grand archives the first sign of danger
with the fire fading and the spreading
puss of man tainting the castle the
grand archives closed its doors for good
today only a few of its keys remain as
the curse of the undead began seeping
into lothric the scholars shut
themselves off from the world and in
doing so cut off the world from the
knowledge of the archives there's no
evidence to suggest that the scholars
attempted to help the rest of the
kingdom during the subsequent dark times
they appeared to have only sought what
would benefit those that dwelled within
the grand archives yet through all their
reckless decisions the scholars were not
completely blinded by their perverse
pursuit of insight they acknowledge that
the immense wisdom gathered from the
archives is paired with an intense
danger the player can see this in the
form of the cursing hands that exudes
from all the bookshelves so the scholars
took precautions against this staining
the robes with wax and tending to their
candles with a reverence that exceeds
the simple burden of Labor for they know
the dangers of the archives store of
knowledge all too well the scholar ropes
seem to indicate that some of the
scholars might have even been lost to
the curses of grand archives the wax
serves as a sort of countermeasure to
the cursing hands forth the player Don's
a head of wax the bookshelves curses are
no longer any threat the scholars were
once the intellectual architects of
lothric but they chose to hide away in
the archives instead forgetting the
outside world finally we have the
priestesses out of the three the least
is known about this pillar though it is
just as credible as the others for in
lothric the high priestess has long been
considered one of the three pillars of
the Kings rule the high priest has also
served as the prince's wet nurse
the current High Priestess emma is
initially the one to help you leave the
high wall and venture out into the
larger world of Dark Souls 3 when she
then summons you back to face the final
lord of cinder prince Lawford
she pleads if Emma was lothric sweat
nurse it make sense for her to care
about him and want you to save him from
the despair he's fallen into this theme
of compassion seen in Emma seems to
characterize this pillar of lothric one
of the identifier of the priestesses is
a focus on miracles as opposed to
sorceries which have a very wide range
of views and come from man miracles
descent from the gods
and I often hone in on healing
protection and fortification doc
counting the Dark One's almost half of
miracles in Dark Souls 3 deal with
healing in some way or the other the
majority of the others do not directly
deal damage the priestesses even came
together with the Knights to help them
fulfill their role as protectors more
proficiently the priestesses taught the
Blessed weapon miracle to the lothric
Knights this blesses the right weapon as
well as gradually restoring health the
night you said to have strengthened ties
with a high priestess after the scholars
acquired the grand archives the Knights
wanted to be stronger in their position
to make up with a great benefit of the
archives gate to the scholars this is
further evidence of a great weight and
importance that he grande
archives poses this animosity between
the Knights and scholars discredited the
notion that the three pillars always
work to serve the king and lothric
together for the betterment of all
however there is actually one more
unofficial pillar of law through the
kings of lothric needed at a loyal task
force that wouldn't get caught up in the
bureaucracy of the larger groups or
answer to the morals of the fickle
masses members of this hidden pillar
were called hunters and the most
excellent are known as the Kings
Blackhand these hunters serve lothric on
the fringes and in the shadows for
generations rulers of lothric have
relied especially upon the black hand
hunters to punish enemies in ways that
the Kings three pillars could
to be a part of this a squadron once
family must have dutifully served the
royal family for successive generations
of Kings to date more than three such
individuals have borne this distinction
clearly this is an exclusive group as it
should be
its members are doing such things as
personally serving and protecting the
royal family only two of these
mysterious hunters names are known guard
and Kamui the movie wielded the weapons
on a kiri a new debauchee as he looked
after the prince of the kingdom he seems
to continue the service to the prince
all the way through the events of the
game as he can be found with two other
NPCs guarding the path Prince lothric
his speed strength and versatility and
weapon choice all attest the
extraordinary skill level that is
required of the black hand hunters
unfortunately come only blocks the path
the final Lord of cinder so he must be
defeated the other black hand got heard
also brandished a pair of weapons the
god are twin swords seems that paired
weapons were a theme for the black hands
he's found dead at the entrance to the
Grand Archives holding the grand
archives key that lets us in his swords
say that he was fleeing the castle why
Goddard was clean can only be guessed
however he does seem to realize the
sorry state of the kingdom as he is
summonable to fight pontiff Sullivan and
abyss Watchers
additionally the player would have never
gotten into the Grand archives without
guitar taking a key outside it seems the
black hand hunters had a falling out by
the time of Dark Souls 3 as Kamui stays
by the side of royalty while godhardt
attempts to help the player-character
fight against the Lords of cinder
including his old masters law books
royalty
the pillars of lothric once maintained
order and balance in the kingdom serving
directly under the king but the curse of
the undead fractured lothric some like a
man Goddard realized that the Lord's
must return to their thrones and did
what they could to ensure that others
such as the Knights of lothric and Kamui
could not relinquish their former duties
and they hold onto them steadfast
protecting fallen ideals and corrupted
lords and their splintered and decayed
forms it's obvious that this kingdom can
no longer stand upon us once great
pillars of all three yo what's up
everybody mad Luigi here and I want to
say a big thank you to everybody that
watch the video up from now I put a lot
of work into this video and it took a
lot of time so I appreciate that you
guys watched it this far and I'm happy
that you guys enjoyed it since if you're
here I'm assuming you enjoyed it a big
shout out to I am NOT here or there a
redditor that put together the majority
of the lore information in this video
they made a lot of posts in the dark
souls 3 Japanese subreddit about Lauryn
items descriptions and all that stuff
and a lot of stuff that was used in this
video so a big shout out to them since
they've been a lot of work to compile
all that if you liked this video I'll be
posting a lot more Dark Souls 3 lore and
general content I have a lot of other
Turtles there comes in already up on my
channel so if you're interested in that
go check it out and if you like the lore
video make sure you stick around because
I'll be doing more of these thank you
for watching and peace out